je suis très déçu et
j'ai l'impression que
nous sommes comme des Allemands
maintenant
ceux qui en ont la possibilité
les gens sortent manifester mais c'est
complètement interdit les gens sont
arrêtés sous nos yeux montés dans des
autobus ça fait partie d'un
environnement de censure qui est à son
cœur à son comble depuis ce matin
qui diffusent qui est jugé de la
désinformation par le Kremlin s'expose
désormais à une peine qui peut aller
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
[Musique]
il faut dire ce qu'on doit dire parce
que c'est notre profession et aussi
c'est notre attitude mon attitude
et après on verra
le crème
voici maintenant une vidéo qui vous
montre des soldats canadiens
les multinationales puis bagages Boing
Nike
encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
qui est devenu toxique ici Tamara
Alteresco Radio-Canada Saint-Pétersbourg